hello and welcome to the desi autonomous
systems open house my name is Jane
Shepherd and I'm the head of alumni at
Udacity thanks for joining us today to
learn about Udacity --zz manager you
programs and opportunities in the field
of autonomous systems we'll start
today's webinar by introducing you to
David silver the head of autonomous
systems here at Udacity David will tell
you just what autonomous systems are and
then give you an overview of different
focus areas within the field he'll
explain the learning paths Udacity
offers and how we prepare our graduates
to apply their skills to undemanding to
two of our alumni so they can share
their experiences with the nanodegree
program and how they're using their new
skills and their careers several Udacity
team members are also with us today to
answer your questions throughout the
webinar so feel free to type your
questions or comments into the chat box
we've got a lot to cover in 45 minutes
so let's get started with our overview
of the world of autonomous systems
please welcome David silver head of the
school of autonomous systems at Udacity
welcome David hello everybody and thank
you for the kind introduction Jane my
name is David silver and I weed the
school of autonomous systems here at
Udacity the school the autonomous
systems consists of our nano degree
programs that teach students about
robotics and self-driving cars and
flying cars we'll talk a little bit
about what the school is and a bit but
first I just wanted to introduce myself
briefly I've been the Udacity for about
two years I came to Udacity from Ford
Motor Company where I worked on their
self-driving car team
um just up the road in Palo Alto
California Udacity based in Mountain
View which is the next town south and I
came here specifically to build our self
driving car nano degree program and I
now have the fortunate experience of
working not only on our self-driving car
program but also on our flying car
inanity program and our robotics
nanodegree program and some of our other
programs as well before I worked at Ford
I was a normal Silicon Valley web
software engineer for about ten years I
don't know if anybody on the line knows
what that red icon
Ruby that's the Ruby programming
language that was my language when I was
a web software engineer Ruby on Rails
and a few years ago I got really excited
about self-driving cars but I didn't
have a background in automotive software
or robotics so I started taking classes
online at Udacity and other places and
eventually I was fortunate to get hired
on to the team at Ford Motor Company and
the folks at Udacity saw that and said
why don't you come to Udacity and build
out for other people essentially what I
had done for myself a path to working on
self-driving cars so I've been at
Udacity for the last couple of years
working on that and it's been delightful
Udacity is an awesome company it was
founded by an awesome leader sebastian
thrun sebastian is not only the founder
of Udacity but also in a lot of ways the
father of the self-driving car sebastian
was a professor at Stanford where he led
the Stanford team that won the DARPA
Grand Challenge the hundred mile race
through the California desert that
kicked off the self-driving car boom in
2005 and then he left Stanford and went
to Google where he founded the Google
self-driving car project now known as
way mo and after a number of years at
Google um he left to found Udacity and
bring Stanford level education
um to the entire world and so a Udacity
we get the pleasure of working both on
self-driving cars and education for
everyone in the world and it's been a
really delightful experience to work at
Udacity and with Sebastian so I
mentioned the school of self-driving
cars has three key components flying
cars self-driving cars and robotics I
mean those are our three most advanced
programs and we'll talk about each of
those in a moment
and then we have an introductory course
called intro to self-driving cars which
is a course that teaches are a program
that teaches students the prerequisites
in order to be successful in any of our
different programs flying car
self-driving car or robotics so flying
car deals with both flying cars and
autonomous flight things like quad
copters and actual flying cars that
companies like Kitty Hawk and Z arrow
and and even some of the commercial
aircraft carriers are producing
self-driving cars teaches students the
entire autonomous vehicle software stack
from one into the to the other deep
learning and and perception all the way
through to motion planning and control
in robotics teaches the core sends
perceive act or sense plan act paradigm
for for any kind of robot whether it's a
robotic arm or a vehicle in motion or
any other robotic system in each of
these programs focuses on the jobs in
those fields so if you're interested in
working in the the flight field then
flying car would be the best program for
you if you're interested in working in
self-driving cars and other vehicles
that that are in motion on the ground
then self-driving cars a great program
and if you're interested in robotics for
things like supply chain or
manufacturing or healthcare surgical
procedures other types of approaches
then the robotics the under degree
program is a great program to to proceed
into and the prerequisites for all these
programs are very similar um what we
expect students to know when they go
into these programs are basic calculus
basic linear algebra on basic statistics
things like mean median mode probability
distributions and in basic physics as
well as intermediate level programming
ability um ideally in Python or C++
because those are the languages of these
programs and if you if you feel like you
just need a little bit of a refresher in
any one of those areas um then there are
lots of courses both at Udacity and
elsewhere books that you might be able
to brush up on on something but if if
you want to kind of get a refresher to
all of those topics or many of them then
our intro to self-driving cars program
is a great program to do that this
program is specifically designed to
teach the skills that you need in order
to be successful in any of our more
advanced programs and so if you're
coming to us with more of a software
programming background but you act a
little bit of those engineering
fundamentals and then intro to
self-driving cars could be great for you
and if you're more of a core in
but you have less experience programming
them the same thing intro to self driven
cars will teach you the programming
skills that you need to be successful so
let's take a look at our self driving
car engineer nano degree program would
start first with with the jobs in this
field this is such a hot field right now
and we'll hear from from Abby in a
little bit about his job search and how
he landed a job working in this field
but you can see how dense on this
ecosystem is I'm kind of in the center
you have what are called OMS original
equipment manufacturers or just
automotive manufactures these are the
brands that everybody's familiar with
Toyota mercedes banz Ford and these
companies are supplied by a network of
what are called Tier one automotive
suppliers and these are companies you
may have heard of or maybe not AB Denso
in Japan Continental in Germany Delphi
and in the United States these are
companies whose entire business is
supplying automotive manufacturers with
the different components that they need
to put cars together in all of these
companies both the manufacturers and the
Tier one suppliers are investing heavily
in autonomous vehicles and have big
self-driving car teams working on either
entire vehicles or specialized
components for those vehicles and even
more specialized than the Tier one
suppliers are to your two suppliers
companies like in video which produces
graphics chips companies like Bella dine
which produces laser sensors Android
auto these are different companies that
have very specialized roles and they
produce things like graphic chips for
example that that are important for
self-driving cars but often get packaged
up by a tier 1 supplier into an
automotive grade solution and so these
tier 2 suppliers also have really large
autonomous vehicle teams and then
downstream from the automotive
manufacturers we have this whole new
ecosystem emerging with tech companies
like way mo and Apple and Samsung that
are building autonomous vehicle teams
and then ride-sharing companies like
uber and lyft and DD that are looking to
turn their ride-sharing networks into
autonomous vehicle transportation
systems all of these companies again
hiring lots of self-driving car
engineers so the self-driving cars
nanodegree program Udacity is a
six-month program and it covers the
entire autonomous vehicle stack software
stack in the end and what it's really
designed to do is train you as a student
with what you need to know in order to
get a job working in the field so we
start with computer vision
um this is taught by um by us in in
partnership with a drew gray who was
formerly an executive at uber ATG now
actually at voyage we move on to deep
learning which is a more dense set of
mathematical algorithms or tools really
that can be used to extract data
particularly from camera images and has
really transformed the way that that we
do computer images and perception
generally in the autonomous vehicle
industry and for this week we partnered
with Nvidia and uberta to teach the most
advanced topics in the field and then
the final module in term one is sensor
fusion which is how we fuse together
data from different sensors in order to
gain a more coherent and complete
understanding of the world so not just
cameras but also lasers and radar and
other sensors
so that's term one which is um about
three and a half months and then term
two is more of a hardcore robotics
sequence of modules so we have a
localization module which is also talked
with mercedes-benz and this is how the
vehicle figures out precisely where it
is in the world you might think we could
use GPS because we all have cell phones
nowadays with GPS and we know where we
are all the time but in fact GPS is only
accurate within about one to two meters
and if you think about how big one to
two meters is if a car were wrong about
where it was by one to two meters it
would be off on the sidewalk potentially
hitting things that would be really bad
so we have to use much more
sophisticated mathematical algorithms
and high-definition maps to figure out
precisely where we are in the world the
next module is is path planning or
motion planning this we also teach with
mercedes-benz and this is really the
brains of the vehicle this is how the
vehicle figures out where it wants to go
and how to get to its goal and that
involves actually a few steps and
predicting what other vehicles on the
road are going to do it involves
deciding what our vehicle should do both
in response to what our goal is and in
response to what we think other vehicles
on the road will do and then finally
planning a trajectory a path for the
vehicle to follow in order to execute
whatever maneuver we select the next
module is control which is how we use
the steering wheel and the throttle and
the brake to actually move the car
through space and follow that trajectory
that we developed in the planning module
and then the final module is system
integration and this is where we bring
everything together and students
actually form teams and write code that
actually goes on Udacity self-driving
car are real self-driving car here in
Mountain View California we give you a
simulator you write code with your
classmates about five students - a team
- to make the car run in the simulator
and then you send the code to us we test
it in our simulator and when everything
checks out we put it in our car and and
have it drive around our test track in
California so let's take a look at one
of the projects that students do as part
of the nanodegree program this is a lean
finding project so so this is actually a
you'll see a video of our car Carla
driving down highway 280 in California
and this is one of our students applying
a number of computer vision techniques
that we teach in the first week of the
course more traditional standard
computer vision techniques to finding
lane lines so you can see looking at a
region of interest which is the area
right in front of us those lane lines
using different algorithms to detect
edges in the image and then using other
mathematical algorithms to connect those
edges together and turn them into actual
lean lines that we can then use to to
figure out where the lanes are and
ultimately where we are on the highway
so you can find a bunch of these videos
on YouTube and I encourage you to go
take a look they're really fun to to
look through if you just search for
something like Udacity finding Lane
lines on YouTube but let's jump to the
next slide and let's talk a little bit
about our flying car nanodegree program
so flying car an autonomous flight
encompasses all
a lot of different employers now we have
traditional aircraft manufacturers like
Boeing and Airbus and Lockheed Martin
we have drone manufacturers like DJI and
zipline and sky do and then there are
actual flying car companies like Kitty
Hawk and lilium and uber elevate is
working on flying cars so there are a
lot of different companies in this space
it's still a little a little earlier
than where self-driving cars are but you
can think of it as kind of where
self-driving cars were maybe five or ten
years ago it's potentially a really
really exciting space to get into now
and kind of ride the wave up we have a
one-term nano degree program for flying
cars I'm like self-driving cars which is
two terms in flying cars we cover three
really important topics for for
autonomous flight one is planning so how
do we plan our route in our trajectory
in three dimensions three dimensions
gives you a lot of extra flexibility
that you don't have in in self-driving
cars and also you just have a lot more
freedom whereas with self-driving cars
on the ground you have to stay on the
road in three dimensions you have a lot
more freedom about how to move through
the world and how to avoid collisions
with other objects because you can
always move up or down which is
something you can't do on the ground we
we have a module on control and control
gets so much more complicated in three
dimensions than it does in two
dimensions in two dimensions we mainly
have to worry about yeah do we steer
left or do we steer right and do we
speed up or do we slow down so left or
right would be lateral control and
speeding up and slowing down would be
longitudinal control forward and
backward control but in the air of
course we have this third dimension and
that means that a lot of things become
more complicated there's a lot more
complexity to coordinate transformations
and making sure we know even which
direction we're headed in and so that's
an area that we spend a lot of time
covering and our flying car program and
finally on state estimation which is
figuring out where we are it's a little
bit like the the equivalent to
localization and self-driving cars where
are we in the world in what state are we
in what direction are we headed in
and understanding what happens when we
when we move our vehicle through the
world or when we change the direction of
one of our rotors so so this is one of
the videos from the flying car nano
degree program this is our quadcopter
flier and you can watch a take-off here
and then proceed along a trajectory in
an urban area and so this is what things
might look like either if you were
flying a drone or potentially as as
flying car companies progress um this
might be the model for for what flying
cars look like right now flying cars are
heavily battery constrained lifting a
person or really anything off the ground
is so energy intensive oh my goodness is
the nervous there the car was gonna
crash and the quadcopter was gonna crash
but it did okay the energy intensity of
getting something airborne is a
restriction on us actually being able to
attach a human to a quadcopter like this
and move them around the city but as
batteries get more and more powerful and
more and more efficient you can imagine
constructing flying cars that look kind
of like this maybe with a person kind of
hanging off the bottom and flying
somebody around the city and these are
the types of simulators that we build
for all of our nano degree programs in
the school of autonomous systems I mean
it's really neat to be able to work with
a really visual project like this you
can see that the quadcopter kind of
bouncing back and forth here along this
trajectory so let's take a look next at
our robotic software nanodegree program
robotics has a lot of different
applications on two of the big ones are
manufacturing and supply chains and
there are lots of companies many of
which are maybe you know a little bit
less household names but they're
incredibly important in the world of
logistics and warehouses and industry
and robots are used to do all sorts of
different things everything from
automating assembly lines to moving
goods and equipment around facilities
and many more things I'm particularly
interested actually in robots for
surgical healthcare I'm some of those
kind of microsurgery type robots our
robotics the under degree program is a
tutoring program
let's take a look at the curriculum here
um we we start off with kinematics so
this is basically the study of motion so
if you have a robot with multiple
different joints what happens when you
when you actuate each of those different
joints and and how does that robot move
through space we then cover perception
how does the robot perceive the world
using different sensors like laser and
radar and cameras we cover controlled
which is just like in self-driving cars
how do we use the actuators whether it's
steering or a motor on a different joint
on the robot to actually move that robot
and get it to do what we want it to do
I'm we covered deep learning which is
becoming increasingly important for all
different types of robotics for
perceiving the world and working with
camera images and then in term 2 we
cover localization again this problem
how do we figure out precisely where we
are in the world particularly with
respect to high-definition maps we cover
something called slam which is an
acronym for simultaneous localization
and mapping so that's what do we do if
we get into an environment that we don't
have a map for how do we move around
that environment and explore it and
understand where we are and where we
need to go we get into a really advanced
topic called reinforcement learning
which is how do we use simulation to
train intelligence into a machine
learning age and a deep learning agent
so that that that agent can try things
out millions and millions of times in
simulation and eventually learn how to
do perform in action or a task
effectively in the real world and then
the final module is path planning how do
we plan a path through the world I'm in
order to move the robot from where it is
to where we want it to go and this is a
video of one of the projects in the
robotics nano degree this is our
pick-and-place project so you can see
this robot or this project involves
controlling a robotic arm in simulation
we're using Ross which is the robot
operating system which is a really
important software package for robotics
also for self-driving car
um it's used as kind of the base layer
based software layer for a lot of
different robotic applications and you
can see the student in this instance
using this robotic arm to pick up an
object off of you know one of those IKEA
bookshelves and move it around and place
it somewhere else and of course this is
exactly the type of application on that
you might use on an assembly line or in
a factory or a warehouse
take a look next at our intro to
self-driving cars the nanodegree program
and remember this is the program that's
really designed to teach the
fundamentals of what you need to know in
order to be successful in either our
self-driving car flying car or robotics
Lander degree programs any of the more
advanced programs so in this nanodegree
program we teach probability we teach
linear algebra we teach programming and
we teach physics we also teach a little
bit of calculus and these are all of the
the fundamental techniques that you you
need to know in order to be successful
in in the world of robotics and
autonomous systems and and it's similar
to what you might get in a freshman
level engineering curriculum in a
traditional University but we're much
more focused on practical applications
at Udacity and and projects and building
actual things with a knowledge that you
learn and so there are a number of
different projects in this program and
and let's take a look at at one of those
now so this is our joy ride project this
project involves controlling a vehicle
and getting it to parallel park so if
you've ever taken a test drive and a new
car cars nowadays often come with
automatic parallel parking ability I'm
okay but not terrific at parallel
parking but it's actually really
satisfying to program a car to parallel
park and you get to program a car in
simulation to parallel park and this is
actually the very first program in the
first week of the intro to self-driving
cars in the intro degree program it's a
four month program designed to really
prepare you with the fundamentals you
need to be successful in the world of
robotics and autonomous systems so so
that is our school of autonomous systems
I think this is such a fun area to work
in it such a fun area to learn about I
love self-driving cars so much I love
learning about flying cars and things
about robotics that are new to me I get
to learn new things about this field
every day and I'm really excited for you
as a potential student to come join us
and learn more about this field too
because it is such an exciting place to
to be learning about and to be working
in right now um so I'll hand it back to
Jane and and Jane can introduce us to
some of our alumni from these programs
help you launch a career in this red-hot
growing field now we'd like to introduce
two alumni from iron and degree programs
to share with you their personal
experiences learning with udacity and
talk a bit about how they're applying
their skills in their new jobs
please welcome I'll be stuck monthon who
specializes in sensor fusion he'll be
joining mercedes-benz in the bay area
and also please welcome
I seen rush Dylan I seen is a software
engineer and event gates in Turkey I
bikini tell us a bit about your
background hey everyone it's great to be
here today so I am an incoming sensor
fusion engineer at mercedes-benz
research and development North America
one of the hiring partners as well as
curriculum designers for the
self-driving car and an attorney program
so I graduated from the self-driving car
in an interview program in May of this
year I started about a year ago and I
actually had an amazing opportunity to
complete the nanodegree during the last
year of my undergraduate coursework at
USC and one of the reasons why I chose
Udacity was one I actually got it
provided me the opportunity to be able
to actually go ahead and implement a lot
of theoretical work that I had done in
my computer science classes specifically
for artificial intelligence and I think
is the case with a lot of different
classes that you get exposed to you do
in your undergraduate years maybe even
your masters there's not a lot of it
feels like there's not a lot of
applicability to the real world and that
was something that I was struggling with
a lot during my time and after I came
across Udacity he's
read out these promotional videos I
reached out to some of the original
students from the first cohort and I got
the chance to learn from their
experiences about why they chose Udacity
and specifically for the self-driving
car program
I mean first off who wouldn't want to
actually work on a self-driving car as
soon as I heard that this is even a
field and there were job opportunities I
kind of went crazy for it and I mean we
got Deauville ITIN and one of the really
big skills that I gained was being able
to actually go ahead and implement a lot
of these really cool complex algorithms
particularly for a localization which I
spend a good deal of my time during
undergrad learning and actually being
able to extend and develop a pretty
comprehensive portfolio can excuse me
containing around 13 different projects
can really help you be able to kind of
show off your chops to potential
employers and so at that point when I
saw the program I immediately applied
and then I was extremely thankful to be
able to join them at the July cohort
awesome thank you I actually got to ride
in Carla so I totally hear you who
wouldn't want to program self-driving
cars it's awesome I have not yet had the
chance to go in a flying car though
which is the minute degree that I shine
took so I psyche tell us a little bit
about your background hi everyone I'm
from Istanbul Turkey I mean a software
engineer almost 10 years actually in
over ten years and now I'm a software
engineer at events gates and we are
working on computer vision projects and
other types of projects and and we make
use what I learn about autonomous
flights on some of our projects on some
of events and I'm a part of a computer
vision project group here in Turkey and
we may also use some of the skills I
learned from flying
earning a degree on those projects and
we also
for a team of flying car alumni and for
work on autonomous flights and will be
coming with awesome projects and I am
also a lecturer at the University
I'm giving lectures about introduction
programming in classes yeah wonderful
that's a wonderful introduction thank
you so much um obvi I'd like to start
with you it's exciting that you'll be
starting a new job can you say maybe
explain which parts of the nanodegree
you think we're most helpful in getting
your job in which one do you think
you'll be using most in your new role so
I think I'm definitely going to be using
a lot of the content from the sensor
fusion module because I think that way
I'll be joining the Sun circuit weakened
team at Mercedes and in particular that
was definitely my favorite component to
work on of the entire interview program
because it sort of synthesizes a really
critical challenge which is where
exactly as a self-driving car at any
given moment and as David mentioned
before using technologies like existing
technologies like GPS which have been
around for some time just aren't able to
give us a granularity that we need in
order to be able to exactly pinpoint
where a moving object is and in this
case I'm looking car and so when you
begin to realize that okay there are
actually other techniques that you can
use to be able to synthesize all this
information coming from different
sensors around the vehicle be able to
produce some beautiful interests of the
view of the car and not just be able to
look at stationary objects but also look
at that anemic objects and so when you
have sort of this complete map around
you not just a geographical map but a
sort of map in terms of all things
relative it really begins to enable your
vision and from there it influences how
the vehicles can be able to move so it
has a direct impact on motion planning
components as well as also control
components so it's really sort of the
big
part of beginning stages of the initial
software pipeline and so term 2 really
helped me to understand what are some of
the really big critical problems in that
area not just algorithmically but also
performance wise and how you to actually
be able to scale this technology out
awesome
I shine you are not starting a new job
necessarily however you're working at an
event planning company and I'm curious
to hear how you applied that flying car
skills to your work in event planning we
may use some older drones to look like
some of guests we make using skills I
learned about also news flights and from
my internal degree so you may use drones
to shoot videos or some different skills
gather information
that's fascinating so drones are useful
probably during free event planning to
scope out event sites and decide how you
would you know plan the event space and
then also I'm hearing you say that
during the event as well for photography
and just making sure that things are
going as planned with the event keeping
control on traffic control and crowds
that's awesome that's really unexpected
so I think David it points out to your
discussion about how each of these
fields opens up to much wider adjacent
fields you talked about the differences
you don't necessarily have to be
programming a flying car but you can
translate these skills into other fields
which is I think a wonderful a wonderful
opportunity I'd like to go back to you
for a moment
Abby um you talked about your work with
Reese Mercedes in your new role and I'm
curious to know I know Mercedes is a
partner that helped us develop our nano
degree but how did you talk about your
nano degree in your interview and what
was their response to the fact that you
were taking this and this taking this
nano degree yeah
so one of the big things I think that
really helped me
after completing the entire interview
program is actually the first step is
actually the career services might
Udacity provides so do the career portal
you had this ability to sort of go ahead
and customize your profile share a
little bit
your personal biography as well as it
automatically linking to all the
products that you've done and so you can
actually pick and choose which products
you'd like to showcase and so I was
particularly proud of my fusion products
that I'd worked on because it was
something that I had definitely
challenged for me being able to complete
that during school but also being able
to use what I learned in school directly
into those products I was really excited
to show it off to people and so do that
career page actually after I had sort of
indicated that was ready to be hired it
I guess was put through the Udacity
system and I showed up on one of the job
boards and a few weeks later I was
actually contacted by mercedes-benz
engineer and so I was extremely excited
for that opportunity to actually be able
to go forward with steps and it was
actually it still feels really surreal
I'm just being able to work on that
content because when I actually want to
go because the company actually meeting
with a lot of the curriculum designers
that were actually featured in the
videos being able to see them in the
flesh it was really exciting and I think
what really helped was Udacity sort of
provided this great stepping stone in
terms of being able to move forward so
what I like to consider Udacity circular
Mouse it's kind of like a lingua franca
because we end up seeing happening is a
lot of car companies right now as well
as startups and tech companies they're
looking for really specialized positions
and people with community specialized
skill set and I think Udacity gives you
that ability to dive deep into a number
of different topics and specifically for
the self-driving car program because
that's a really unique thing that you're
just not getting exposed to anywhere
else and so when I was sort of talking
about my different projects I felt
weirdly really comfortable being able to
have conversations with these engineers
that have been working on these systems
for so long and then grad thate they you
know I had so much to learn and that's
really the big thing I'm really looking
forward to you but I think completing
the UIC program and especially finishing
up what I had sort of a major commitment
to my undergrad course where it has
shown me that uh I think I can
definitely continue to keep learning for
real
and that's what I'm really looking
forward to is this is a sort of a great
experience to kind of exercise my
learning ability to be able to learn
things about myself and I'm a huge
proponent of online education so this
was the first class that I've completed
online and so overall I think it's
really helped me to expand sort of my
understanding of myself but things I
want to work on in the future well it
sounds like you made a good choice
because combining Udacity with your
actual campus learning set you up to get
hired pretty quickly there so well well
played
thank you talked about some of the
challenges you had I'd like to dive into
that a little bit um when you obviously
none of this is just going to be easy
all the way through so what are some of
the things that you you both used I
shine you as well on when you came
across a challenge you couldn't get you
what was set up within the program to
help you get overcome those challenges
and work with your peers or work with
mentors how did you get past the tough
points I think the really the thing that
helped the most was actually the
community forums so one of the things I
realized was all of the community all of
sort of the different threads that
people have posted throughout the entire
to youth and energy all the way back
it's moving back during its inception in
2017 all of that information is still
available online and using community
forums it's super easy to you or to go
ahead and search exactly what it is you
kind of look for and what really helped
me get through that was being able to
see how people had approached different
problems but also understanding what
their problem solving techniques are
because I think fundamentally that's one
of the biggest tech biggest things that
you're going to be able to gain when you
ask your program is sort of the problem
solving or how to be able to go about
thinking through these problems in being
able the architect solutions for them
and so I would say the community forums
got a really big impact for me anytime I
got stuck I was majority my time was
spent going through the forums trying to
figure out exactly what people had done
to sort of get around any particular
obstacle but it also just a great way to
build around the community there's so
many people out there that are willing
to help and I think that's what's really
valuable when it comes to online
education and I think Udacity doesn't
great job sort of moderating that
community I know that the community
moderators are constantly active the the
research groups are fantastic having a
weekly discussion like the first
research discussion I participated in
was back in January that was actually
one of the first research papers that I
read completely and actually being able
to hold a conversation with someone else
about it and so that's what he kicked
off my research experience because then
I sort of learned how to be able to read
through research paper or a technical
paper understand what the key important
topics are all from the community doves
he's been all from the community poems
and so that's a really valuable
experience that I have there that's
awesome it's really inspiring I think to
learn alongside other people and to help
each other along the way I shine I know
you particularly have some experience
with that would you like to share both
your during the nanodegree and even now
as an alum I know that you are active
with the community group yeah one of our
projects was raised heart and maybe it
was also awarded first cohort of sign
carnally degree and I am a completed one
particular and project heart project on
three different computers three
different systems and just helped a lot
from my eight years and my mentors
formed a community and there are some
additional tips they added during and
the project was we were dealing with the
project and this was very a way to see
the community managers are all watching
us and their content managers are really
updating the content really fast I can
see it in my eyes and that was so worth
this and I am first proud to finish that
project and I shared it on LinkedIn and
I got a job interview after death
that's wonderful so just sharing within
the community it sounds like helps you
get through the challenges but also I
think enriches your learning so that you
can both help other people along and
then helps you create this sense of show
the world that you're able to work
collaboratively in a team which is a
huge part of Engineering in general we
have a lot of questions coming in on the
chat David about opportunities for
scholarships so I was wondering if you
could talk a little bit about the lift
challenge and some of the opportunities
that we offer yes
so Udacity has a scholarship fund that
we we put together in partnership with
companies from all different industries
and we offer scholarships related to
self driving our self-driving car nano
degree program but also in other areas
of Udacity our android nanodegree
programs our web developer interview
programs and in particular jane you
mentioned the lyft scholarship lift
which is a ride-sharing company in the
United States sponsored a number of
scholarships several hundred
scholarships actually for students to
take the intro to self-driving cars nano
degree program which is a program that
they worked with us to help build and in
in particular they are hoping to attract
underrepresented minorities and in other
people who are not traditionally as well
represented in the autonomous vehicle
industry to give them the opportunity to
break into the field and we also have
scholarships for many other of our
programs at Udacity and then the school
economist systems and if you are a
student out there who's interested in
applying for one of our scholarships I
encourage you to write to our
scholarships team you can write to them
at scholarships at Udacity com and maybe
we can post in the chat with that email
addresses just so everybody gets the
spelling right and that team will be
able to guide you to the right way to
apply for a scholarship for whatever
program you're most interested in thank
you David
and speaking of scholarships we've also
had some questions from people asking
about whether or not the nano degree
programs are enough to get you a foot in
the door if you don't have a formal
education I know Abby's got a degree and
I
I shined I know you have a degree in
math as well but people are wondering if
these programs would prepare them and I
know you talked about the intro to
self-driving cars helping people get the
basis on that but do you think that
there is a career path for folks who may
not have an engineering related degree
to move into this field yeah absolutely
this is I think one of the wonderful
things about software and about
technology generally is that the level
of certification or what kind of formal
training you need to go through really
takes a backseat to what your skills are
this is a particularly amount R in
Silicon Valley but it's really true
across technology more generally what
people care about is what you can do and
what skills you have and not so much you
know what degree you have that said the
nanodegree is wonderful and and
companies are increasingly I'm excited
about hiring nanodegree graduates but
really what what matters is um what
skills can you bring to your employer
and so we have seen students with all
sorts of different backgrounds
everything from from more traditional
automotive engineering mechanical
engineering to accounting to biology to
neuroscience to of course software
engineering and computer science go
through our our programs in the school
of autonomous systems and be successful
on in the hiring market and giving jobs
I'm in particularly Udacity
project-based approach to learning where
you're really building these portfolio
projects I think I'll be talked a little
bit about that about the portfolio of
projects and skills that you come out
with to demonstrate to employers I think
really helps give credibility to
students who maybe don't come in with
the traditional markers of credibility
like that computer science or an
engineering degree but being able to
point to a github profile and say I
built these things I think is kind of
the 21st century equivalent of being
able to prove to an employer that you're
ready yep I agree showing having I guess
showing not telling and saying look I
built this and showing you're a maker
I'm speaking of the projects though I'm
curious to know which of the projects
you found most interesting
I shine or a bee which was your favorite
project that you worked on in the
nanodegree I think one of my favorite
projects actually was part of the deep
learning module and I mean of course the
sensor fusion module actually loved it
for me the thing that sort of sold me on
self-driving cars and Udacity as a whole
was working on the traffic sign
classification project so this was the
first time that I had sort of ever work
of deep learning at any level
meaningfully and so that particular
project
and the the lessons that accompanied it
were fantastic because there is someone
like me who had never sort of seen that
stuff before I was actually able to get
up and running being able to run my own
models in tensorflow and Kara's and I
felt pretty comfortable doing that as
well as being able to incorporate some
incorporate you know Amazon's AWS and
actually being able to see how these
models might even be deployed at a
larger scale and so one of the really
big challenges from that project and I
think what deep learning in general is
you have all these different hyper
parameters that you have to worry about
and the hyper parameters these are
basically like little levers that allow
you to fine-tune your neural network
that you're designing so that it can
learn and be able to actually draw
helpful conclusions of your data that
you provide to it and this is actually
the first time in my experience
programming that actually felt like a
scientist where you have these different
hypotheses of maybe this particular
known that word architecture would have
operate best if you know I use this
particular learning rate or this neural
network it's going to operate better if
I add more layers to it and you honestly
just don't know there's so much research
out there that's still trying to
determine okay what's sort of the best
structure for neural network and it
really comes down to the types of
problems that you're going to be solving
so remember for that project I had
actually experimented with five
different neural network models three of
them were sort of well-known models Alex
NAT and ResNet which are fairly large
models that were
and intend to be used skill what I
didn't realize was those models actually
take a few days to be able to train on
to be able to get good results and so I
attempted to load something up into my
you know AWS instance and I got a
message saying that I was pretty close
to running completely out of all my
Udacity given credits so after doing a
little bit more research I realized okay
I definitely to scale this down and so
then we were introduced to you the
version below net model that was
actually created by young Kuhn and
Pierre sermon a which is a is my opinion
a very beautifully designed neural
network because it was very lean but we
also got introduced to a lot of
optimization techniques to be able to
sort of make our neural network be able
to operate a little bit more efficiently
and so I went in and sort of
experimented with a few different things
and I ended up coming out with a neural
network architecture that gave me a
great accuracy score on my test set and
so that was extremely rewarding it was
just really late at night I remember I
actually sat in the room for almost
twenty five hours straight I didn't
actually leave he's kind of worrying in
that respect but being able to just sit
there and work on all this and just
pulling all these little levers I had
never had that much fun programming in
my life that's awesome so it sounds like
it mine that had been your favorite
project all the way through the
experience but at the end I started I'd
like to hear about your favorite project
in the flying car native degree yeah
mine was the third one I was poking you
like this before
a Facebook of Isis experience and it was
actually in information for me because I
am wasn't come from mechatronics or
aerospace engineering background so I
was scared for the first time this is my
turn tentatively for the first time I
might fail but I was one of the first
one finished it's been another great
flying higher in degree and the third
project is controlled project was a lot
of mess
equations we have to deal with and
because my mathematics background I have
a really fun
dealing with them and maybe most of
other students wouldn't like this but
it's really for me to deal with math and
if I that it will project change those
equations to help and make them work um
and drones and a fear that in simulation
it's really a fun to watch and that's
wonderful so I shine works with drones a
bee works with cars David you've worked
with cars and all of the above we have a
question from our a couple of questions
around the future of using autonomous
systems to help people who are disabled
blind using a wheelchair so what do I'd
love to hear from all three of you on
what your thoughts are on the future of
using these systems to make lives better
for everyone yeah I'm just gonna jump on
this one because that's what I'm
extremely excited about so I think that
when you look at the industry right now
a lot of people are focusing on
self-care and cars and flying cars is
you know such a recent ban sment that
there's a lot more traction moving
towards that I think what is really
going to be very pivotal for society is
when we begin to introduce more robotic
systems basically socially assistive
robotic systems in particular when you
actually for example these case being if
let's say your grandparents your
grandmother your grandfather needs help
to be able to move around the house but
there's for example no sort of human
palliative care worker over there to
help you is there sort of an autonomous
system that you might be able to install
that could be able to get from one place
to another or be able to you know help
them with their additional needs and so
that's something that I'm extremely
passionate about and I hope one day to
people to work on that in depth and so I
think that it's interesting because when
you look at sort of the pipeline for
whether it's a flying car whether it's a
self-driving car
whether it's a robotic system in general
it kind of matches a pretty similar
framework where you have issues that
relate to actual perception of what the
autonomous system can see and perceive
around it within its environment you
have a issue of then being able to
actually have the autonomous system
control and use its manipulators within
its environment to move around or to
complete a particular task and then you
have and and and that particular problem
of motion can be broken up into a few
different things right you'll have sort
of path planning component or you'll
have sort of the additional control
theory component and so these these
these frameworks end up following
something that's pretty similar and it's
pretty across the board right now as we
sort of as we understand mostly robotic
systems to be and I think exposure and
depth into one of these particular
fields will allow you to move into
another fuel pretty easily because then
you're able to sort of attach like this
mindset of okay I've seen the problems
that are related to motion 2d on a car
okay I have to add a third dimension
which is how do I get that to actually
fly so when you begin to sort of
simplify the processes there mentally I
think when you're developing these
mental models you're able to sort of
provide these segues for yourself
internally just relating back to
something you've seen before and I think
that's sort of a learning paradigm that
a lot of people naturally sort of do but
when you start to see this implemented
in code you can pretty easily tune
yourself to figure out exactly where you
need to be to update the system or to
work on any component of it really
that's awesome I shine there David do
either of you have any thoughts on how
these technologies can be used to assist
others I can talk a little bit about
about this I think that for me the kind
of high level thing to remember is or
that I think about is is that I think
self-driving cars are gonna change the
world in ways we just can't even imagine
yet
and if you think about
all the people who with the world as it
exists because of how car centered and
driver centered it is in how the world
will change for them in that of course
is everybody from young people living in
cities who don't you know have a place
to park their vehicle but it also
involves people who are disabled who
have a hard time you know controlling a
vehicle that's designed with a
traditional steering wheel and pedal
system to people as they get older who
who maybe don't have the physical
capability to to conduct an automobile
or at least to do that safely one of the
biggest groups supporting autonomous
vehicle development in the United States
right now are are the AARP Association
American Association of Retired Persons
as people get older mobility is still
really important for them but but
driving becomes more difficult and then
groups representing disabled people and
in fact we have some former colleagues
of ours here at Udacity that that left
and formed their own company called
voyage that is building self-driving
cars and they right now are running
their self-driving cars in retirement
communities in different parts of the
United States and that is you know there
are a lot of reasons why they're doing
that but one of them is that that people
in retirement communities still want to
want to get around they want to lead the
same types of lives they've always led
but but things get more difficult as you
get older and and this is a great way to
give freedom to people who otherwise
would see their lives kind of
increasingly restrained and constricted
over over time as they age so I think
just the potential to make people's
lives better and to give everybody kind
of the fuller richer experience of
mobility that many of us already enjoy I
think is really exciting that's kind of
the dream right doing something you
enjoy doing and really helping other
people in the process it's kind of a
perfect mix there where we're running
close to time and we I want to make sure
we get in the last couple of questions
here we did get a question in obby you
mentioned that you used career services
we had a question about how much support
you get from Udacity after graduating
from the mandatory program when it comes
to looking for jobs
whenever you could dive a little bit
deeper
both of you into how he utilized Udacity
screw services and how it helped you
find your roles definitely yeah so one
of the your particular profile within
Udacity services and so one thing I
really like about it is you have access
to you sort of resume reviews LinkedIn
reviews github reviews and when you have
another pair of I is basically take a
look at you effectively um it can feel
really daunting I definitely felt quite
scared when I sort of got feedback I'm
also just like friends taking a look at
my stuff as well because I felt like oh
my gosh like what can i improve I
honestly just don't know and my biggest
suggestion is to take it all and just
put big arms and take it all in stride
because any additional feedback you can
get can just help you shape into a
better candidate but also I think just
as a better person and so within the
career services I really like the fact
that there was access to so much
materials so interviewing interviewing
tips how to be able to actually
negotiate which is I think something
that doesn't actually pop up a lot in
conversations um so that the negotiate
as well as being able to understand
offers understanding like relocation how
to assess particular job opportunities
what do you what do you think you're
good fit or not those are all things
that I think that I definitely was not
sort of expecting I needed to focus on I
thought that you know just shouldn't my
exposure to the industry just threw a
lot of friends I thought okay is will
understood the ins and outs how to be
able to navigate this and I realized
after looking at a lot of the
information that you daddy was sending
forward I just didn't really know as
much that product one or as much as I
thought excuse me um and so that was
really helpful just being able to
use what other people say and then you
know maybe not necessarily using exactly
what they say but doing so in a way that
you feel comfortable with it because at
the end of the day you are marketing
yourself and that is something that's
that is pretty critical in being able to
actually put your name out there and
there's so many ways of doing that I
think the LinkedIn is definitely one of
the biggest things that I used I think
having the ability to message so many
professionals around the world at your
fingertips is really worth doing it and
whether you know you decide to go with
an accountant or even not a paid account
regardless you get access to all of
these people in the world and I like to
kind of consider the world is sort of my
playground and so if there's someone
that I'm like interested in working with
or aren't you I just started shoot them
a message and I think Udacity but help
me gave that coffee's that's wonderful
the power of the network is and I know
we shown you spoke earlier about the
group of alumni that you're working with
to develop projects together so I think
not just getting the job of the support
from I think that Network even after you
get your job in continuing to grow in
the field in other ways is super
important so I want to thank you all it
looks like we are out of time
thank you David Abby and I shine for
joining us today and thank you to
everyone who tuned in asked your
questions and showed your interest and
you'd ask these learning opportunities
it looks like we've got several classes
that are starting up soon now in August
and September so David can you run us
through the options of people's next
steps yes yes so for each of the
programs in the school of autonomous
systems you can see the relevant
upcoming dates here and we hope you join
us the next cohort of self-driving car
students will start in September and the
application deadline for that is
September 2nd so so coming up in a few
weeks our intro to self-driving cars
program the next class will start
September 11th and so enroll by then
robotics the next class will start
August 28th and that's the enrollment
deadline and then the flying car an
autonomous flight nanodegree program the
next class on the application deadline
is August 26 they're just
in a few days and you might notice there
that a couple of the programs have
applications and a couple of them you
can enroll directly in the program the
reason we have applications for our
flying car and self-driving car programs
is basically just so we can help you
make sure that you start in the right
place to be successful we want everybody
who wants to become a self-driving car
engineer or a flying car engineer
robotics engineer to have that
opportunity and if you apply to our
self-driving car program or a flying car
program we'll take a look at where you
are and we'll either say we are really
excited to have you join our
self-driving car flying car program
straight away or we might say you know
we think the thing that will help you be
the most successful is to start with our
intro to self-driving cars program build
up those prerequisite skills over the
course of that four month program and
then you'll be ready to go for four
self-driving cars or flying cars or
whatever it is that you'd like to do but
regardless of which of these options
you're most excited about we are
delighted to have you even thinking
about joining the school of autonomous
systems at Udacity and I just think this
is such a fun and exciting area to work
in and I feel so lucky everyday that I
get to work on self-driving cars and
robotics and autonomous systems and I
hope that wherever you just had to go
with your career you get that type of
joy and excitement as well because it
really is just delightful to be in this
field thank you David and David runs an
amazing team so you'll see there's an
email address here if you do have
questions feel free to email the school
of a/s at Udacity comm and they'll help
you sort through which programs might be
best suited for your interests thank you
again to our amazing alumni for joining
us and to david and thank you to all of
you stay curious and keep learning
bye-bye bye-bye